bonjour je m'appelle et merci pour
lévitation
[Musique]
l'été 2010 c'est une tournée européenne
pour gartenberg
et elle vient aussi à paris c'est à
l'initiative d'un député qui est
matthieu orphelin et alors là je me dis
ah peut-être un coup à jouer c'est à
l'assemblée nationale chez nous
contacter directement matthieu orphelin
ce que je m'explique c'est que nous on a
du temps et ça sera pas simplement cinq
minutes de great attenberg etc ce deal
qui s'opèrent à savoir marc on va faire
cette captation et on va fournir le flux
pour les autres chaînes et puis on va
pas se mentir sécurisant pour lcp d'être
en exclu et d'avoir ce temps d'avant sur
les chaînes d'info en continu l'icône de
la grève pour le climat arrive à
l'assemblée nationale la suédoise gré
attenberg est accueilli par matthieu
orphelin le député écologiste qu'il a
invité ceux qui sont venus l'accueil
plutôt bien ceux qui ne veulent pas
boycott en fait ils le disent largement
sur les socios le jour j
les truites sont sont très violents
c'est on n'a pas bonne presse en
culottes courtes
elle suscite encore de l'hystérie des
comportements qui sont pas tellement
rationnelle mais c'est vraiment le rôle
dès le cp un moment donné de se dire on
a vraiment une discussion qui peut se
nouer sur un dialogue citoyen avec des
parlementaires sur la question de
l'écologie de la transition énergétique
ce n'est pas grave après tout nous ne
sommes jamais que des autres vous n'avez
pas le devoir de kilos gain de les
écouter
par contre vous avez le devoir d'écouter
aux scientifiques
ceux qui sont venus l'écouter sont
plutôt attentif intéressés voire vont
félicité great attenberg et une fois de
plus la réponse de battles merck et est
assez cash à elle elle n'est pas là pour
pour séduire elle est là effectivement
pour donner son message d alerte un
message assez abrupte j'ai entendu
beaucoup de gens qui disent merci vous
me donner de l'espoir pour l'avenir
j'ai l'impression que vous n'avez pas
bien compris ce que nous disons donc
plutôt que de louer ce que nous faisons
essayez vous de faire quelque chose on
sa part sur des réseaux sociaux comme ça
qui sont avait déconnecté très large
s'est repris par de multiples personnes
ça a été le cas même aux états unis un
d'alexandra octavio cortese qui reprend
le tout est donc le tout lcp voyage un
petit peu partout dans le monde et ça
permet un tour du monde du logo lcp ma
grâce à ces images c'est sous ce que
nous faisons un test d'une night
serrières les scientifiques
quand on arrive de toute façon à avoir
en excluant dirais que ce genre
d'événement c'est bon pour l'audience
mais c'est plus largement que ça c'est
plus de visibilité pour la chaîne et sa
lassitude lorsqu'elle événement
l'assemblée comme une chaîne
incontournable
[Musique]